sorry about the Unabomber style
manifesto that I'm reading from but it
makes it sort of easier for me to look
at my well-crafted bub so I study
failure which doesn't always make you
the most popular person in an
institutional setting but I find that
failure is really interesting and that
we should be spending more time talking
about failure in e-government and
e-learning and perhaps less time just
celebrating accomplishments I'm also
interested in an area called procedural
rhetoric and what that means is that i'm
not just interested in verbal or visual
rhetoric so rhetoric about computation
but i'm actually interested in the ways
that platforms interfaces and code shape
rhetorical interactions in other words
create the conditions for communication
in the public sphere or the the
constitution of what might be called in
brutal or tours words you know things
public and i also am an administrator i
run a program interdisciplinary program
called culture art and technology that
is devoted to doing experiments in how
higher education could be different if
we try different forms of active
learning a lot of it is technologically
enhanced some of it is very low-tech and
a lot of it involves things like art
making and public engagement in
communities so i'd like to tell a couple
of stories today and then maybe offer
some ways that those stories could be
unpacked so i'm going to tell two
stories about transgression and so i'm
going to kind of jump into the first one
here GMA the woman's voice said when she
answered the telephone on the opposite
coast the acronym was unfamiliar to me
so it took me a moment to realize that i
had the right number for good morning
america and was calling the correct
person back
the popular ABC television show months
before I had written an item on my blog
about the existence of online cheating
videos created by high school and
college students that demonstrated
elaborate techniques designed to boost
examination scores the video shows
showed step-by-step how to create fake
drink bottle labels in Photoshop to hide
formula how to stuff pin shafts with
answer scrolls and how to write detailed
information about foreign language
conjugations on stretched out rubber
bands most of the videos had low
production values and were shot in
domestic settings but at least one
japanese video borrowed the actual form
of a commercial distance learning unit
with distinct chapters on the subject of
cheating and the lessons were elaborated
with slick information graphics and
computer-generated animations to enhance
the instructional content my story about
those academic dishonesty videos on the
popular video-sharing site youtube had
been picked up by The Chronicle of
Higher Education then a reporter from
the Shreveport shreveport times ran an
article about the subject for which I
was interviewed which later appeared in
a large circulation paper the Chicago
sun-times from there the story reached
researchers at Good Morning America who
thought it had the right kind of
national light news appeal for
mainstream audiences who might be waking
up to their broadcast or watching
television over breakfast before
starting morning commutes although I was
an academic good morning america
apparently hoped that I might be an
adequately colorful commentator for the
show to speak to the phenomena of a new
kind of online dishonesty I thought the
cheating videos were interesting because
they demonstrate an argument that I've
been developing over the course the past
decade first formal institutions of
codified pedagogy represented by
universities and informal learning among
people who are largely self-taught we're
increasingly in conflict when it came to
their respective everyday practices and
long-term goals second access to and use
of compute
national media frequently exacerbated
this tension I thought the situation was
particularly unfortunate in an era of
socially networked computing where one
would hope that academic and popular
forms of instruction would be converging
to work in concert to support a lifelong
culture of inquiry Collective
Intelligence and distributed research
practices certainly the students in the
video were sharing tips and performing
online knowledge networking activities
that constituted a form of real learning
even if it would be considered
objectionable by their professors who
would understandably see it as a
fundamental violation of the scholarly
social contract in these cheating videos
the students were demonstrating that
they understood the procedures of their
own educational institutions and how a
different approach to the sequences of
operations involved in the minutiae of
tests taking my guarantee higher scoring
success they had achieved mastery of
something that seemed relevant to
success in the University but it wasn't
what their professors wanted them to to
have learned in their courses of study
in addressing the hundreds of thousands
who watched such videos students weren't
the only ones the implied audience these
videos appeal to many non-academic
viewers who enjoy watching the hacking
of obstreperous or powerful systems
academic viewers who enjoy watching the
like videos about fooling electronic
voting booths hacking vending machines
opening lock cars with tennis balls or
smuggling counter contraband goods
through airport x-ray devices obviously
i'm showing my own YouTube viewing
habits by giving you that list of things
because pretty much I love those videos
too and these two cheating videos also
belong to a broader category of YouTube
videos for do-it-yourself enthusiasts
those who like to see step-by-step
execution of a project from start to
finish online YouTube videos about
crafts cooking carpentry decorating
computer programming and installing
consumer technologies all follow the
same basic format
and popular magazines like make have
capitalized on the subculture of avid
project-based participants although
these cultural practices may seem like a
relatively new trend one could look at
DIY culture as part of a longer
tradition of exercise devoted to imitate
a 0 or the art of copying master works
which have been central to rhetorical
instruction for centuries unfortunately
by the time the production offices for
good morning america called my
university months after my initial blog
posting the story of these students acts
of ingenuity had become transformed by
the producers into lurid evidence for
yet another internet moral panic
somewhere between the predator panic
when the news seemed to be all about
innocent young people as the prey of
online sexual deviance and the bullying
panic about the cruelty of the young
themselves toward their peers there were
a variety of miscellaneous panics being
aired on national television with
horrified glee my conversation with gmas
the GM a staffer quickly became strained
and not just because my travel schedule
was hard to accommodate the show clearly
wanted a voice of moral outrage that
defined the defended tradition and
condemned the lacs values of the young
from the elevated position of a
stereotypically highbrow college
professor several times I was prompted
to say how reprehensible I must think
the behavior of the video makers was at
the same time the woman from ABC was
unable to suppress her voyeuristic
pleasure and having lined up two of the
actual student perpetrators who produced
the offending video so they could be
paraded through the public in there
unrepentant condition so that's story
one is cheating videos on YouTube so
then there's a story to on story two
takes place at my own institution so
your story too in 2010 I visited course
designed to teach digital literacy
skills to college freshmen those being
held in three rooms one offered a live
faculty member pacing the stage
while the other rooms presented a
broadcast version of her performance it
was a required general education course
that focused on teaching Alice an
object-oriented computer programming
language designed for k-12 students with
a simple graphical user interface I was
skeptical about whether alice was the
right programming language to teach
college students but I knew that the
lecturing faculty member had a good
reputation for innovative teaching and
deploying student-centered learning
techniques so I was coming to class with
an open mind at the beginning of the
quarter students in all three rooms had
purchased wireless handheld clickers
that could monitor their class
attendance and assure their attention
did not wander too far from the subject
matter during class time and hopefully
measure their performance at reaching
the courses stated learning goals during
my visit to the class I soon notice the
students perked up each time the screen
displayed multiple-choice questions
about computer programming techniques
only because they had to select the best
answer quickly among several plausible
choices as a digital clock counted down
not all of the questions on the screen
were straightforward problem solving
tasks about choosing the right line of
code or the right order on the right
operation sometimes the questions
involve fundamental definitions or more
abstract reasoning about why to choose a
particular approach to encourage
collaborative learning students could
also periodically confer with each other
in small groups and debate the merits of
the different answers in the clicker
room with the live performance by the
professor I watched about 45 minutes of
a college instructor trying to do
everything right in addition to clicker
quizzes and small group discussions she
encouraged active learning by soliciting
questions and comments from students
using a microphone despite her best
efforts about half the students in a
lecture hall were partially engaged they
only paid attention during the quiz
portions of the session much of the time
these students seem to be considerably
more interested in non class related
activities on laptops and cell phones
that involve games and social network
sites
the other half behaved more attentively
like students who could see the
professor and be seen occasionally there
were small dramas in a lecture hall when
a student could not get his or her
clicker to function and there would be a
flurry of desperate activity around
supplying batteries for the dead clicker
from clickers that had already clicked
in before the ticking clock ran out of
time I then went to a large lecture hall
to the immediate right of the live
lecture where no professor was actually
present it was part of an initiative
intended to pilot a distance learning
course that would teach computer
programming to AP computer science
students who might not have such courses
offered at their high schools which was
being tested on first-year students no
one was at the podium of this lecture
hall the faculty lecture appeared only
is a fuzzy apparition moving around on
the right screen the room was brightly
lit like the first lecture hall but
students were much more disengaged from
the spectral lecturer and her phantom
interactive activities even though the
content delivered was identical to that
in the room just next door and they were
also being held accountable for the
content periodically with clicker
quizzes almost all of the students in
this class we're texting and web surfing
all around me with only brief pauses to
answer quiz questions with their
clickers some of the students were
engaged in highly inappropriate behavior
students applied makeup talked on cell
phones and held conversations at regular
volume with each other about matters
unrelated to class in this lecture hall
small group discussions quickly strayed
into non class related topics and
student teaching assistants patrolling
the aisles with a microphone I asked a
graduate student teaching assistant
patrolling the aisle with a microphone
if students were ever discouraged from
pursuing such non class related
activities and he said never sitting in
that lecture hall I felt as though I was
watching an experiment in digital
learning that had gone terribly wrong
but no one seemed willing to tinker with
the experimental protocol or question
the basic assumptions about learning and
teaching
were dramatized in a lecture hall the
ones covert war between us and them had
turned into an open battle between our
technologies and their technologies on
the one side we faculty could reset
countdown clocks and forgive clicker
mishaps but they had access to wireless
networks and mobile telephony my
sensibility is an educator were somewhat
assaulted by this spectacle of mutual
disrespect but it seemed futile to try
to engage anyone present in a
conversation about what they were
perpetuating and why for the last 15
minutes of my observation I took refuge
in a much smaller room which was
configured like a large classroom rather
than a lecture hall and located to the
left at a live lecture the room was dark
and the broadcast instructor was to the
left of the live lecture I'm sorry the
room was dark and the broadcast
instructor was projected with close-up
shots on a relatively large screen where
students could clearly see the
professor's facial expressions in the
intimacy of the room while viewing the
same instructional content this group
was much more attentive than the group
in the larger brighter space and behaved
as if at a movie theater with reverent
silence I was dispirited to see that
there was also less interaction among
students with each other during the
discussion portions this room however
was standing room only there was a kind
of peace to be found in the passive
darkness a respite from the war on
learning being staged under bright
lights a few doors down so those are two
stories about bad behavior bad behavior
at home bad behavior in the classroom
what can we sort of say about the bad
behavior and maybe where we stand on it
so the war on learning explores the
assumption that digital media deeply
divided students and teachers at a once
covert war between us and them has
turned into open battle between our
technologies and their technologies so
we the faculty control course management
systems online quizzes
wireless clickers internet access to
powerpoint slides and podcasts and
plagiarism detection software on the
student side they are armed with
smartphones laptops music players
digital cameras and social network sites
and seem to be masters of these
ubiquitous computing and recording
technologies that can serve as advanced
weapons that allow escape to virtual or
social realities far away from the
lecture hall or exposure of that lecture
hall to the outside world should they
choose to document and broadcast the
foibles of their faculty each side is
not really fighting the other I argue
both opponents are conducting an
incredibly destructive war on learning
itself I see problems both with using
technologies to command and control
young people and force them into
submission to establish Authority and
with the taupe Ian claims of advocates
for DIY education or unschooling who
want to embrace a libertarian politics
of each one for himself pedagogy and
defund public institutions devoted to
traditional learning communities and
collectives to promote totally
autonomous learning and individual
private homes effective educators should
be non-combatants I'm claiming either
champions of the reactionary pass to the
radical future and making the argument
for becoming a conscientious objector in
the war on learning I'm focusing on the
present moment both sides in the war on
learning are also promoting a particular
causal argument about technology of
which I am deeply suspicious both groups
believe that the present rupture between
student and professor is caused by the
advent of a unique digital generation
that is assumed to be very technically
proficient at navigating computational
media without formal instruction and is
likely to prefer digital activities the
reading of print text I've been a very
public opponent of casting students to
easily as digital natives for a number
of reasons contemporary anthropology
supplies a host of arguments against
assuming preconceived ideas about what
it means to be a native when studying
group behavior I'm particularly
suspicious of this type of language
about digital natives because it could
naturalized cultural practices further a
colonial uttering of the young and
oversimplify complicated questions about
membership in a group furthermore as
someone who's been involved with digital
literacy and now digital fluency for
most of my academic career I've seen it
firsthand how many students have serious
problems with writing computer programs
and how difficult it can be to establish
priorities among educators particularly
educators from different disciplines or
research tracks when very diverse
populations of learners need to be
served yes I think the argument you're
making is that the dire problem is
because people are being labeled as
digital natives versus the problem being
that classroom techniques which are
being used I just wrong for anybody well
I mean I i think that there's definitely
labeling going on and I think I one of
the things I talk about is because the
irony of the fact that that some of the
more interesting digital pedagogues are
now people who are retiring their early
adopters who are actually leaving the
world of digital media learning and that
younger people who are coming into the
Academy often there's a study by someone
named Diane Harley who's at the center
for studies in higher education at
Berkeley who looks at how people teach
in a higher education setting and what
she's discovering is that there's
there's a lot of conservatism among
faculty new faculty young faculty in all
disciplines not just humanities
disciplines because they're being
advised by senior faculty members to
just play it safe and be very
conservative in the ways that they teach
and really focus on research and just
you know kind of go get tenure don't
take risky experiments don't you know
don't try crazy things with your
students don't do things that won't pay
off and so I mean I think that using age
is a marker for competency is always a
mistake developmentally speaking
but I also think that development is
really an even I'm just not sure that
that's the only problem I think there
are a lot of problems you think are
whether the argument here is that the
major problem is leaving or the major
problem is that people don't know how to
teach in this new video right because
the example that you gave with that
split between three classrooms to me
seems to say that university doesn't
really know how to you know what's the
right answer to this question well I
think this there's a great temptation
when you have computational media and I
get into that later when i get to the
case of my favorite guy that the the
baked professor i don't know how many of
you have seen this video this is a
business professor who was involved in a
distance learning course at the
University of Florida and he began to
give his lecture and he had both live
students and remote students and he
began his lecture by saying listen my
children and you will hear and started
like to recite Nursery Rhymes and then
he started talking about the origins of
different obscene words and he flipped
the bird at the camera and he did a
variety of kind of very bizarre
activities and he of course became an
internet meme I don't know how many of
you have seen this the baked professor
video or any of the remixes of it so
there was a psychedelic remix I mean
like anything that is made on the
internet but what's interesting about
the video are two things that community
are interesting about the video that
people miss the first is he had minders
in the room so even though he obviously
was under the influence of some
pharmacological subject substance you
know he was clearly in an altered state
during the time that he was giving what
should have been a more conventional
lecture there were people
who were participating in this sort of
instructional technology spectacle and
the fact that his authority as a kind of
lecturing figure like nobody was going
to stop him no matter how crazy he got
because it was an entirely one-way
communication so he could get just as
loony as he wanted but the rules of
engagement were such that you know that
there was no way to kind of control him
and certainly the instructional
technologists were not facilitators of
learning in any way they were just there
to record his performance and make sure
that everything went as it was supposed
to go which of course it did not at all
so that's one interesting factor about
this video the other interesting factor
however is the subject of his lecture
was actually scientific management and
the second part of the lecture when he
is so people have all seen the first
hour of his lecture when he he rolls
around on the floor he's like I mean
he's he's using all sorts of language
that you wouldn't normally use in your
in your in a teaching interaction um he
comes back after the break he's still
clearly disinhibited but he's kind of
got it together a little bit more he's
got this lecture on scientific
management planned right so he was going
to go over theories about industrial
production in ways that techniques of
scientific management were used to kind
of rationalize labor in the late 19th or
early twentieth centuries so he starts
talking about distance learning in
scientific management and he starts
essentially complaining about the
structure of distance learning as a as a
kind of attempt to scientifically manage
the academic labor of his institution
which was an interesting thing to say
again not something that was necessarily
appropriate to say or rhetorically wise
for him to say no one paid any attention
to this part right the kind of deeply
subversive critique of his institution
they all focused on the kind of wacky
hijinx of him rolling around on the
ground
but what's interesting about it is that
this this when you when you're working
with computational media and distributed
networks and you can quantify all of
these things about educational
interactions the temptation is strong to
do so like when you when you because you
can mathematically model information
exchanges of various kinds and model all
kinds of interactions the tendencies to
focus on the things that can be
mathematically represented so you get
forms of learning that privilege things
that are easy to represent
mathematically that rather than ones
that are hard to represent
mathematically and you also get into a
that in the name of doing these
experiments like so the in the case of
the professor giving the the three
lectures simultaneously I actually did
try to talk to people about how badly
those classes were clearly going and
like you know like it seemed relatively
easy that like a TA could just ask
people not to just text through the
whole class like why couldn't there be a
human interaction where you know if you
need a laptop for a disability reason
please sit in the front row if not just
please close your laptop please don't
talk to your neighbor like you know and
they actually said that that they had to
do this sort of scientific protocol they
had to run the experiment all the way
through to its disastrous end because
otherwise it wouldn't be a legitimate
experiment so I think that they're so so
there's this tendency toward
quantification but there's also a
tendency toward thinking about education
in terms of highly objectified protocols
rather than this is ironic to me because
there's all this research in cognitive
science that shows how how learning and
neuroscience that shows how learning is
closely tied to affect an identity and
all of these things that are actually
really
not about quantifiable outcomes and it
seems that at a time that sort of
science is actually telling us that
emotion matters and effect matters we're
we're defining learning in increasingly
kind of dis dispassionate quantifiable
ways that sort of answer your question
the long answer to the rescue dog yeah
there's some there are a lot of problems
and it would be probably my answer maybe
I should sort of talk for a minute about
angry professor remixes which is
something I'm kind of interested in too
so there's a saying among people in the
instructional technology movement then
the saying is distance learning begins
in the second row anyone who's observed
a traditional large lecture hall course
in the past decade recognizes the truth
of that statement and the serious lack
of empathy or emotional connection that
many students the back row the lecture
halls of today feel toward they're
physically remote college and structured
instructors from the cynical perspective
of these highly disengaged students
professors might just as well be
audio-animatronic robots in the higher
education theme park in which they plan
to spend the next few years in merriment
and diversion with their friends no
wonder such students would band together
to make cheating a rite of passage the
logic goes when professors seem
unimportant and test scores are the only
things that matter and and I realize
that you know I when I say that you know
people here at Stanford me like oh
thanks aren't like that at Stanford no
maybe not that would be good if they
weren't that way professorial hostility
towards students anywhere beyond the
first row seems magnified by access to
technology so this is a fun experiment
type the words angry professor into a
search engine and be prepared for videos
or professors destroying digital devices
or chiding their students for
inattention
the many remixes parodies and hoaxes
generated around these angry professor
videos demonstrates trying to police
student distraction this way only seems
to feed the trolls but might be less
obvious to the uninitiated is that many
of these incidents showing supposedly
inflamed faculty performances online are
actually hoaxes or spoofs some such as
teacher break student phone now at over
a million views have obviously can
dialogue and are quickly called out as
phony by viewers i have a strict texting
policy professor destroys cell phone and
that's of course the title of the video
right has earned almost 700,000 hits
despite a faculty member looking at the
camera awkwardly and a history lesson
that would be too simplistic for most
high school classes nonetheless a campus
newspaper took the texting policy video
as genuine and ran a related story about
class policies and disciplinary
consequences that such a professor might
face for destroying student property
other videos may have more complicated
reception histories if they've been
passed on through online social networks
as genuine evidence of faculty
retaliation for exasperated student
behavior for example professor Kieran
Mullen a condensed matter theorist at
the University of Oklahoma explains on
his faculty webpage that the video that
shows him shattering a student laptop he
is frozen in liquid nitrogen depicts
violence done to a machine that was
quote non-functional before freezing and
that the putative owner is a quote plant
from a willing student accomplice
whoever Moen goes on to assert that the
video does enhance his message about how
students quote in a large lecture class
can be distracted by others watching
movies reading news websites and playing
games on their laptops he also notes
that he had quote warn students many
times about not using their laptops
during lecture and that his
demonstration did have the desired
effect of improving student attention
another video in which a professor
destroys a cell phone and you know as
somebody who's interested in
interactions between people and devices
I'm also working on a project that's
kind of a
epilogue to the virtual politic book
that's about obama and his use of smart
technologies because i'm kind of
fascinated with how is the blackberry
shown on the flickr page for the
president and how do we how do we see
obama interacting with technology
because of course on the campaign trail
the image was Obama with his laptop and
at least one smartphone in front of him
sometimes too and so we have sort of the
image of the multitasking president and
now if you look on the official flickr
website you see obama is often shown
with like a corded phone you know in
this sort of John F Kennedy kind of pose
where he's kind of doing Cold War
diplomacy on a on a landline because
that's presidential and there's no
multitasking because multitasking would
be unpresidential and that when you see
the blackberry it's kind of hilarious
because the blackberry appears like he's
either in the dark outside off stage
like the message is always like yes you
could check your blackberry but you have
to be somewhere else so anyway that's a
long digression on Obama and
instructional technology at and smart
technologies but I'm also interested in
like why these angry professor videos
why students why devices become the
objects of violence like what is it
about the interaction between student
and device that's so in so much a kind
of cultural stereotype and that even
these like hoaxes or spoofs it seemed
seem to be taken as genuine because
there's such a strong belief in this
animosity toward the device by faculty
and that that there's a kind of wish
fulfillment that's playing out that has
this kind of power to it
crumpling up newspapers and stuff like
that or I mean does this take whatever
the current technology is and get mad at
it or is there something different about
laptops believers um I would argue that
yes and yes that that you can you can
argue that there's been a long history
of the instructional technology movement
that has looked at everything from you
know using television in the classroom
Marshall McLuhan in his 1969 Playboy
interview famously talked about TV as an
educational tool to film strips to all
these other sort of interests in how
media function in relationship to the
educational situation there was a comic
book panic where there was anxiety about
how comic books would undo educational
settings so I'd say yeah there's there's
a continuum of both wanting to use new
media for learning and feeling that new
media work against learning I'd say the
thing that's different is that
distributed networks that the the
ability to to connect with remote others
is different that I think that it's it's
it's harder to the classroom situation
is changed by that experience and I also
think that the ability for students to
self-organize more rapidly around those
technologies and some of the the sort of
student rebellions that I look at have
to do with students taking advantages
digital technologies to do kind of flash
mob behavior in the classroom you ever
see subverting the subversion today's
you see the staff actually use similar
or different technologies sort of get up
get around these emergent crisis I think
there's an interest in trying to co-opt
social media behaviors to try to
I think they're two approaches to
anxiety about the behavior of students
one is let's put in command and control
let's put it you know let's emphasize
policing student behavior but then
there's a kind of kinder gentler
approach which is oh let's let's try to
use the technologies ourselves and I
also fascinated with like terrible just
tone deaf attempts by administrators and
department chairs to try to kind of
create media that students would find
appealing with like no idea of like how
that would work yeah I think that um I
think that that the problem is that the
social realities of faculty and the
social realities of students are very
separate and I think that we don't have
good technologies for facilitating
social learning yet I think you know
trying to use Facebook to foster
learning or Twitter to foster learning
is a very difficult proposition to do
well on some people what
well I give a couple of different
answers I'd say there are expectations
about genre and that that what you
produce when you you know for a
particular situation doesn't always
translate well to the academic setting
I'd say that's one challenge I'd say
that that it's difficult to negotiate
multiple authority position
simultaneously and people don't know how
to do that well they don't know how to
both be an authority figure and not be
an authority figure online that it's
it's it's easier to do when you have a
lot of paralanguage tick information
it's easier to do like an office hours
situation where you can kind of
constantly test how the interaction is
going I think it's harder for people to
do electronically when they don't have
the same sense of how it's going but I
think they're probably even more
problems with with doing it well you
know doing it well party is actually the
last chapter of the book which is the
part I am not really good so I always in
my books with the like this is the you
know this is all you know several
chapters about disasters and poorly
conceived ideas and then the last
chapter is going to be all about like
the way forward and as somebody who
cares about the way forward I should
have more answers to that but I actually
think it's incredibly difficult I'd say
one answer is sometimes ditch the
technology go to old media have students
produce books have students you know
work with paper prototypes have them
just do things you know think about
technology beyond digital technology
think about you know I have a kind of
riff about clothing as a technology you
know how can we think about clothing as
a technology that can be used in
different ways to promote different
kinds of social behavior between people
so I think there are a lot of things you
can do as an educator to sort of change
things up I think the mistake
is either taking the one-size-fits-all
command and control approach that
administrators say you should do or I'm
just trying to kind of be a student and
act like a student because you really
can't act like a student and be an
educator at the same time does that make
sense so a little bit more about angry
professors because I have angry
professors now what might be less
obvious to the UH okay I I told you
about the freezing laptop guy so this is
my favorite guy this is he's shown right
here um if an authentic angry professor
moment is captured and Ernest either by
students with cell phone cameras in the
audience or by tech support recording
the class for posterity such outbursts
might be remixed remediated or parodied
later after Cornell lecture marked
Albert shown here interrupted his lesson
plans for two minutes to seek out and
castigate the student hood admitted what
he called an overly loud yawn his
faculty temper tantrum was watched by
over 700,000 people on YouTube I think
it's over a million now in the video as
Talbert insists on maintaining the
boundary between what he calls informal
and impolite he makes theatrically
menacing comments like and this is an
actual quote my bad side is as bad as my
pleasant side is pleasant hunts for the
offender among the rows of anxious
students armed only with their
electronic clickers and finally yells at
the guilty party should walk the hell
out soon after the video was posted
talbert became the subject of ridicule
with theme t-shirts a facebook organized
yawn in to protest classroom conditions
and a number of at a number of dance
remixes featuring digitally digital
modulated synthesized versions of
talbert's eruption with my badge that as
bad as by pleasant side as pleasant
serving as the refrain so there's some
fantastic auto-tuned angry professor
videos some angry professor incidents do
prove to have actual physical and legal
consequences for faculty
who lose their cool at Valdosta State
University professor Frank Rybicki was
charged with battery after closing a
laptop in the hands of a 22 year old
female student who refused to go offline
during his mass media class rybicki and
accuse her of the number of these cases
that involve people working with either
media or technology yes of course
something that you can't it's never like
the the medieval French history class
that happens it's always always in one
of ours so rybicki eight accused her
visiting non course related websites and
an argument had ensued students who came
to vicky's next class meeting were
greeted by police officers who had come
to interview witnesses and warned
against discussing the case on twitter
or facebook yet generational allegiance
would do little to shape T's in the
Rybicki case in online comments many
students at VSU express support for
their professor and contempt for their
classmate over 100 students joined the
team rybicki facebook group that was
created to rally others to his cause and
to organize protests to his treatment by
authorities a number of youthful
supporters were team Rybicki t-shirts to
the trial in an interview after his
acquittal Rybicki described how he quote
went to put the laptop down she tried to
pull it away from me and she claimed her
finger got stuck although rybicki quote
didn't see the finger get stuck and
argued successfully at trial they had no
intention to cause her any physical harm
although rybicki argued that the real
issue in the case was the right of the
professor to maintain the classroom as a
learning environment university
administrators were still planning to
terminate his contract and to end his
tenure track employment as a result of
the altercation so what's interesting to
me is that this is also a global
phenomena and you'll find these angry
professor videos in at least a dozen
different languages on YouTube and you
see both remixed ones you see ones that
are hoaxes ones and you see the same
pattern of the angry professor moment
that involves an interaction around
technology that involves this higher
setting in which things get out of
control sorry kind of talked about the
this particular case the the stone
professors case and the question of kind
of how you manage telepresence I think
it's also interesting to notice how the
engagement problem gets imagined as a
question of how students student faces
function as a kind of interface so have
any of you seen this video it's called a
vision of students today by michael
wesch it has a huge number of views so
in a vision of students today a group of
Kansas State students over 200 students
hold up signs as they describe their
alienated condition so some of the signs
say things like I will read eight books
this year two thousand three hundred web
pages and 1281 Facebook profiles I'll
write 42 pages for class this semester
and over 500 pages of email I Facebook
through most of my classes I bring my
laptop to class but I'm not working on
class stuff so what this is a video that
people who are arguing for digital media
and learning in higher ed often point to
as an example of why it's necessary to
take action however the story of this
video is actually a little more
complicated so this is actually an
outtake driven in the video it's one of
the things that people have pointed to
is the that is pretty obvious when you
look at the kind of just the faces of
the students as a kind of display
mechanism and they stand they sit there
and passively while they hold up these
cards is the absence of students of
color and a WESH said well no there were
students of color in the class I just
ended up not using that footage and so
the question became we'll wait so you're
editing this footage
because the the kind of myth of this is
that this is this participatory student
project that this was supposedly created
on a Google Doc so all 200 some students
created this composition by
collaboratively working together on a
Google Doc and yet WESH says oh but I
you know there was this interesting
moment about race but I edited out
because it didn't seem like there was
time for it so what I might suggest it
would have been a more progressive thing
to do might have been make the whole
database of film clips available to all
the students let them remix the
collection together as they chose the
other myth about this video that the
this story about the the excerpted
student points out is supposedly this
was written by students in this google
doc as a prepared class exercise and yet
when wesh explains about the outtake he
says well a lot of students just wrote
things on cards the day of the filming
and this was an example of just
something that they did not as part of
the Google Doc collective enterprise but
it's something that they did
spontaneously on their own but I think
what is interesting in thinking about
this question about kind of how do we
think about the classroom itself as a as
a space in which we're thinking about
interfaces there's a comment by mark
Murray know that I think is interesting
he says following up on his highly
played and first web two point O video a
WESH focus is this video and how today's
students have changed with respect to
their relationship to classroom
technologies and technologies brought to
the classroom such as laptops cell
phones and pens in this video which uses
a superimposed quotations and other
comments to make a point that seems
implicit in part of using that that
technologies offer new possibilities but
do not completely eclipsed or race
previous technologies in this case he
juxtaposes contemporary technologies
with that preeminent display technology
of the blackboard further his students
also become display media
or rather that shows the ways in which
they can use any surface including the
walls of the room as sites of
inscription means of participation
directly contrasting with the blank
screens of their faces and the reports
of their less than full class
participation so if you haven't seen the
video you should definitely take a look
at it so maybe since I want to allow
plenty of time for discussion let me
just maybe a look at the last so we
talked a little bit about using a video
technology as a way to create an
impression of telepresence so that
students outside of the physical
classroom can have a classroom
experience somewhere else there are also
experiments in higher education that
have to do with ubiquitous computing and
bringing in mobile devices particularly
sort of large distribution experiments
involving freshmen so the idea is you
give all freshmen an iPad you give them
all an ipod and I want to tell you a
little bit about this experiment which
involved giving all incoming students
this was actually from my own
institution a wireless device and this
took place 10 years ago so this is an HP
giornata mini computer many of which
ended up on ebay or as part of a waste
but but there were some interesting
things that came out of the experiment
so let me just say a couple things about
this experiment so mass distribution of
handheld digital devices to first-year
students on college campuses offer new
ways for undergraduates to read the
university and its interfaces and to be
instructed in new modes of digital
reading by campuses interested in
promoting electronic rites of passage
that are markedly different from those
of the codex book
with mobile technology students are
encouraged to read text books read
buildings and even read each other in
ways that seemingly counter
traditionalist anxieties about post
literacy in the distraction panic how
should we look back at a decade of
large-scale distribution efforts aimed
at giving mobile computing to first-year
college students for case studies the
2002 distribution of HP jordana pocket
pcs at UC San Diego the 2004 distribute
distribution of iPods at Duke and the
twenty ten and twenty eleven
distributions of iPads at Seton Hill and
the University of Maryland tell us about
institutional attitudes about how
students should decipher the messages
encoded in higher education what's
interesting to me about these these mass
distribution efforts i call them gadget
distribution effort is that when you
look at the surrounding rhetoric of the
distribution you find out a lot about
how the institution thinks it's solving
a particular problem involving the
university so you also find out how
people are imagining their own
institutions and what they think they're
solving by distributing these devices so
when you look at the material
surrounding the UC san diego
distribution and Bill Griswold wrote a
lot of interesting things about the
distribution he wanted these devices to
be able to allow students greater access
to spaces of the university that were
otherwise invisible so he imagined the
device as as sort of being able to make
visible faculty and research
opportunities and things that would
otherwise be set off kind of closed off
behind closed door by being able to kind
of hold up this kind of magical window
now Duke when they handed out iPods they
had a very different idea about the
university they wanted it they primarily
wanted it not as a decoding device but
as a recording device and so the idea
was this first year of college is this
magical time and here you have this big
data device that lets you capture
everything and the problem the reason
you need this device is because you
you just can't take it in fast enough so
you need this device that will that will
be more efficient than you as a note
taker and you will be able to capture an
archive all of this stuff from your
college experience um the the ideology
on the iPad is not as clear other than
kind of I think a fascination with
either paperless pneus or are kind of
interest in using QR codes as a way to
toot again decode university spaces and
places but it's it's not quite as
clearly about access in the same way
that I think this distribution was sort
of trying to be so really when every so
every pretty much because I had I went
and watched a lecturer a third of the
students had paper third of the students
had laptops and the third of the
students have ipad there wasn't control
experimenter just about the fractions in
class as far as I can tell all the
students with paper were paying
attention taking notes all the students
iPads were following on the slide
student engaged in class and everybody
who had a laptop was on Facebook or
doing other work and so it was an
interesting the medium predicts your
engagement right moment and it was funny
because in one of the imports this has a
very actually unwieldy user interface so
using this pin is actually really
difficult for students to do they argued
that this was actually a virtue and that
students so had to concentrate on doing
the input that they couldn't possibly be
surfing the web or doing other
activities because it took so much
attention to just operate the device so
it's a kind of interesting case in which
the device is sort of determining the
interaction another way well let's open
it up to questions so I sort of save you
thinking about the university as a
design problem or thinking about the
kind of tension between participatory
sure and the Coursera experiment maybe
for our discussion and kind of let you
know that I'm part of an experiment
called feminist dialogues on technology
that's trying to do a series of linked
online and offline courses that where
materials are sets are shared a little
bit more biologically and where students
can be content creators of the course as
well so thank you yes so my question is
kind of like related towards someone
else asked in the 50s maybe you had
people kinda escape the reality of comic
books or newspapers order so it's kind
of like now in suppose Stanford partners
but like a third-world country or
something where people don't have cell
phones or laptops but you're still like
over the internet broadcasting some
lectures has anyone done any studies
like that to make it seem like what the
attention span of people would be such a
because it seemed like everyone just
because these studies based in places
where people have access to like each
other people so that you're asking a
really interesting question and there's
a lot of research that was done on the
the One Laptop Per child project some of
it pretty critical of the kind of
missionary mentality of the and the ways
that it it assumes that kind of a
problem can be solved with a consumer
device if do you know the work of
Francois bar who looks a lot at how
people use social and public computing
and what what his researchers often
found is that people preferred having
info me diaries' that they actually
didn't necessarily want direct access to
information they actually preferred the
social interaction around around the
information rather than just having the
kind of the fantasy of sort of direct
access without an intermediary isn't
something that's universally appealing
to people in all situations I think in
the Coursera case there's a lot of
discussion about
how this allows forms of elite Western
higher education to reach beyond kind of
First World institutions which is I
think both a lot of a goal and one that
should be always thought about
critically so what is it what does it
mean to assume that you're not co
constructing knowledge with your
participants elsewhere what does it mean
to kind of just use the kind of
broadcast model as a way that could have
a kind of missionary component to it as
well in spreading a certain kind of
ideology about what learning should be
that might not necessarily match I mean
there's also a lot of interesting
research by build more about digital
money Mobile Money and his group the
Institute for money technology and
financial inclusion that looks at how
people are using mobile money around the
world in ways that don't necessarily
match the kind of narrative about
entrepreneurship and capital that will
magically spread with the devices that
actually there's a lot of fighting
between families and struggles about you
know how the device changes social
interactions and the last piece that I
think is important and thinking about
with Coursera is that the you know
eighty percent of the people who are in
Coursera courses abroad have higher ed
right they have college degrees already
and I think one of the things I
discovered from when I went to his meet
up I actually drove up with a 25 year
old computer programmer from Belarus who
had a degree from a former Soviet Union
country but she felt wasn't recognized
in the United States and wasn't valued
and so it was that strong desire to have
that us brand associated with your
educational profile that I think is
actually sometimes a strong motivator
for people to want to participate in
these courses and you know W
JT Mitchell wrote was the name poison
ivy was the essay that he wrote about
the kind of branding of American
Universities he did this whole thing
about Harvey versus at my team I'm a
Harvard person and I thought it was
absolutely completely true so that
there's that that what's desired is a
branded commodity rather than an actual
learning experience sorry Sophie long
rant like final battle array between
students and teachers I I argue that
that's actually not the real battle that
that that's a false way to imagine
what's happening that what's really
happening is that they're these kind of
two sides that have these different
ideas about technology but they actually
share common assumptions about the
digital generation and neither of them
are really helping the educational
situation very much because they're kind
of arguing for this either you know
let's go entirely digital let's blow up
the university you know the university
is the problem not the solution
professors are the problem not the
solution or you have people who just
want to return to some fantasy of 1950s
America that never was he's based on my
reading of media history really like you
or I under got it never really seen
problems associated with students using
laptops or smartphones in class like
I've never seen a professor the agitated
that students might be multi tasking at
the same time is that different some
universities there's yeah and it might
where'd you do your undergrad University
dildo yeah I mean there are certainly
complaints from you to receive which
switch campus yeah it's certainly heard
uh faculty they're complaining about
about distracted students
the question is is distraction really
the problem might be the the real
question is or is it that students don't
feel the learning is meaningful maybe
that's the real problem and maybe we
need to instead of reducing distractions
we need to focus on how students can
feel that learning achieves some goals
for them like how is you know this is
the reddish it in me right it's all
about audiences and purposes so who's
the audience and what's the purpose like
those seem up animal question things no
these issues don't really have to do
technology at all and then I guess the
question being then how the technology
module is the underlying issue in
particular or something like you know in
a large classroom as a lot of people are
paying attention that's terrible for
them and better is not kidding and you
return on their money or their spending
on education and like how we view that
so many people go to college today just
because that's what you do we have to do
it and so specific that any sort of
arrangement would get these kids to be
engaged maybe you know a lot of paths of
this yeah there's certainly a lot of
people who would argue that the problems
have more to do with large kind of
macroeconomic patterns involving
pressures on universities to deliver
certain kinds of education and not
others I recently spent a week with our
faculty from our visual arts department
who are doing a kind of visioning
retreat process and a lot of them a lot
of that education is you know according
to bean counters very expensive because
you work in small groups on design
projects and you can't you can't scale
it up so this that the
this that many might argue that the
tensions have more to do with pressures
for changing academic labor than really
technology itself technology and
distractions and that there might be a
deeper underlying cause seems really
similar to being medicine for
distractions that right it feels really
parallel yeah it was funny to hear you
talk about the first time you were on
television the first time I was on
television I was in a documentary called
failing to learn learning to fail it was
a documentary about what was then called
hyperactivity and now we call a DD or
ADHD and we were the successful family
because we we had money and we had
ritalin and and my brother and I were
both sort of shown as being a kind of
exemplary upper middle class family who
you know the kids were so it was like
three failure stories and then we were
like the success story and it actually
ended with my brother like literally
running on the beach off into the sunset
you know as Cat Cat Stevens music plays
and of course uh you know that ritalin
proved to be incredibly destructive and
you know there were things that I found
out about that family dynamic that was
definitely not helpful and that
certainly medicalization is something to
be critical of in much the same way that
assuming that a technology solves a
problem you should be you should ask
questions about I think technology makes
things more interesting but I think when
it solves one problem it often creates
other one ones and that can be
interesting too yes
sometimes near talked you said something
about we are measuring objectives which
are not affect and effect is known to be
important for nothing right I i wonder
if the problem is that fear measuring
something was not measuring anything at
all the begin with are having moved from
measuring epic to not measuring happen
well if you say i don't care about
assessment I think you will pretty much
you can't hold and ministry to post at a
university of this this country I carry
deeply about assessment because I think
it creates an opportunity for
conversation so I say yes go ahead and
measure things so that you have things
to discuss but realize that but watch
out for assuming that that that progress
is always that you can get a narrative a
progress or a narrative of crisis out of
the set of measurements that you've made
their it measurements help you identify
problems that you can then talk about
and I think actually the solving of the
problems has more to do with the
conversation than the measurement and
that often it's even got really
defensive about those measurements and I
think that's not helpful to there are a
lot of super anti assessment people
particularly you know I'm part of this
kind of feminist camp of academics a lot
of those people like really they will
say assessment is anti-feminist and they
really strongly believe in that I
disagree because I think otherwise if
you don't have these activities there's
no common rhetorical object for people
to have a conversation around like
there's no you're not creating at that
energy that focus that people need
brother mr. P don't have a quantization
our assessment time and we don't know
assessment I would say that okay I tend
to be on the side of more conversation
rather than less as you can probably
tell
that's probably good night
you